you are the first I think you're the
first tyronn de I've met I haven't I
don't think I've met another Conan so
it's like I got whole name but how did
that yeah that was a trump high-five
this is not that's not cool
this right here I felt that you look a
little fews I don't think you did well
how'd your appearance plumpest hi Rhonda
really yeah I'm sorry mom I got to tell
the story I'm so sorry
my mother was dating two men at the same
time Taiwan and Ronny Tyrone and Ronny
yes and all my siblings name start with
it see mm-hmm and she was local fused
and no she kept both of them like yeah
we need book bags in this thing we got
everything we wanted out of them you're
named after boy yeah was my father my
dad's name is Derek
oh she's gonna love that story
you're a rapper in your spare time yes
you as you're a you passionate about rap
absolutely what did you write your own
stuff absolutely okay well can we hear
anything is it yeah okay sure
and then after I'm done you I'll do my
rap yeah thank you so much you're right
yeah I bought like MROs e that's rose so
much money on Meeks in my pockets that
faith see I'm notorious I repeated b.i.g
got tools over 21 like a state ID swag
SiC thank God I got a PhD my wrists cold
I think it's too much
I see eat even if you had binoculars you
can't see me but I must say flexor Rd I
eat
[Applause]
yeah hey thanks for watching please
subscribe to my youtube channel so they
will stop making me shoot these videos
please